well I think we can say now in
retrospect that 2023 wasn't much to
write home about it was a 12-month
period so dull and unimpressive that
Taylor Swift won Person of the Year by
default but as we tracked and discussed
throughout the year for a company like
Disney 2023 was something Beyond merely
unimpressive it was downright
catastrophic in fact Disney's self-
imulation was for the rest of us one of
the year's only major bright spots if
nothing else at least we all got to
watch Disney lose a bunch of money and
uh so the year was not a total waste in
hindsight the New York Post details uh
this week just how bad things got for
the once a great movie studio reading
quote 2023 Mark Disney's 100th
anniversary of making movie Magic it
also marked a disastrous year at the box
office out of eight major theatrical
releases from Disney this year seven of
them significantly underperformed with
audiences not just in the US but
overseas as well the first was in
February with Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania despite an All-Star cast
including Paul Rudd Michael Douglas
Michelle feifer and Bill Murray the $200
million $200 million priced film earned
only $250 million domestically and $476
million worldwide far short of the $600
million it needed to break even on its
theatrical run now presumably uh 600
million dollars represents its
production and marketing
budget because Disney spent well over
half a billion dollars making and
promoting a film about a man in an ant
costume who runs around punching bad
guys and as I understand it
communicating with
ants the from what I'm told that's one
of the superpowers of this superhero is
that he can communicate with ants which
how does that even help you when you're
fighting bad it's like a very specific
kind of bad guy that you would need that
that would help you with
I mean like a bad guy who's the size of
an ant and in that case why do you need
communicate with you just step on him so
I don't know but you know in fact um
this film actually was a sequel so in
total Disney has spent over a billion
dollars on the guy in the ant costume
franchise they could have provided food
for like 50 African villages for a
thousand years but instead they spent
the money on
Ant-Man now I'm not one to complain
about inequities okay but uh this is a
bit much and that was only the first of
their flops as the post highlights
another superhero movie the Marvels had
a $274 million budget but still hasn't
cracked $100 million to the box office
and the flops continued from there quote
uh movie goers showed signs of being
tired of recycled material from
Hollywood Disney had a lot writing on
its liveaction remake of The Little
Mermaid starring Hal Bailey released in
May it earned a respectable $27 97
million domestically but greatly fell
below expectations International Al
earning just $267 million overseas the
film had a $250 million budget the next
month Disney released Indiana Jones in
the dial of Destiny starting 81-year-old
Harrison Ford it gross just $174 million
domestically less than $400 million
worldwide making it impossible for the
studio to recoup its budget of nearly
$300 million which does not include
marketing costs Disney closed out the
summer with its reboot of Haunted
Mansion making a dismal $68 million
domestically and $117 million worldwide
the $150 million budgeted remake
starring Rosario Dawson Owen Wilson
Danny DeVito Tiffany Hades Jam Le Curtis
and Jared Leto DA's 2003 predecessor
starring Eddie Murphy which was also
considered a major disappointment still
grossed $182 million worldwide with a
$90 million budget so in case you missed
that uh just to review they spent $150
million remaking a movie from 2003 that
was a flop the first time
around it no one wanted to see it the
first time and then they did it again
and no one wanted to see it the second
time so of course we have to try a third
time maybe it's I mean if if Haunted
Mansion didn't work out and the remake
of Haunted Mansion didn't work out well
then I've got an idea the remake of the
remake of the haunted mansion that's
what's going to get butts in the seats
so they're just layering flops on top of
flops dud after dud and then they remake
the dud and that's a dud too and it's
not hard to see why Disney is failing so
consistently you don't you don't need to
consult any marketing analysts or PR
gurus just ask any average movie goer
and they will tell you I mean literally
walk up to anybody on the street and to
ask them how they feel about Disney
right now and when they tell you they
don't really that they don't like Disney
ask them
why and they'll there'll be two reasons
they give you two reasons why people
aren't watching Disney movies the first
is that the films are almost always
rehashed stale overdone played out they
aren't producing anything original or
interesting I mean Disney films are so
unoriginal and derivative that you would
think the scripts are being written by
Claudine gay which in fact they sort of
are or by people like her which brings
us to the second reason that audiences
of course are tired of the left-wing
propaganda in these films Disney movies
just like the movies from any other big
Studio are preachy and
derivative you know and and that's it
that's the problem that's what almost
any movie go no matter how they identify
politically will tell you and that means
that the solution for Disney as we
mention at the top is pretty simple just
make movies that are
original or at least somewhat original
and also not
political another way of putting it
focus on telling stories again just tell
Disney for so many years was it was a it
was a
storytelling company they told
stories and get back to that that's all
you have to
do but that does not appear to be in the
plans for Disney in 2024 instead they're
going to double down on everything that
audiences hate and that's why the
company announced a few days ago that
they will be producing a new Star Wars
movie this year so you know we're we're
going we're rehashing again we're going
back to the Star Wars well and it will
be directed by a feminist
journalist so they are giving the Star
Wars franchise not just to a feminist
but to a feminist journalist the
independent reports shine oade chenoy
who is set to become the first woman and
the first person of color to direct a
Star Wars feature film has said it's
about time the 45-year-old Pakistani
Canadian filmmaker made her name as an
Oscar winning documentarian before going
on to direct two episodes of the Marvel
series Miss Marvel her Star Wars movie
which has been written by peeky blinders
Creator Steven Knight is rumored to be
titled either Star Wars A New Beginning
or Star Wars new Jedi Order is set to be
begin filming this year quote I'm very
thrilled about the project because I
feel what we're about to create is
something very special OB obey chinoy
told CNN during their coverage of new
yearor celebrations around the world
we're in 2024 now and it's about time
that we had a woman come forward to
shape a story
in a galaxy far far
away yes it's about time it's about time
that a woman shapes a Star Wars story
now of course every Star Wars film and
TV show for the last decade has already
been shaped by woman Kathleen Kennedy is
the president of Lucas film and the last
Star Wars Trilogy was about a woman was
about a female superhuman Jedi
person but even so this is an historic
moment because they're adding yet
another woman and and this woman is the
most feminist of them all and just to
show you that here she is uh a few years
ago um before she was selected for for
to be in the Star Wars franchise here
she is explaining what her goal is when
she makes a film and you might you might
if you don't know any better you might
think oh her goal when she makes a film
it must be to tell a great story that
people want to see oh no it's not that
uh here it is
watch what is the balance of activating
a force for
change but also trying
to permeate that patriarchy that power
structure and is that a part of the
calculation of your art as well and and
what's been the reaction to that oh
absolutely um I like to make men
uncomfortable I enjoy making men
uncomfortable
not you just
just point taken point
taken but um you know it is important to
be able to look into the eyes of a man
and say I am here and recognize that and
recognize that I am working to bring
something that makes you uncomfortable
and it should make you uncomfortable
because you need to change your attitude
and it's only when you're uncomfortable
when you're Shifty when you have to have
have difficult conversations that you
will perhaps look at yourself in the
mirror and not like the reflection and
then say maybe there is something wrong
with the way I think or maybe there is
something wrong with the way I am
addressing this
issue there's your next Star Wars
director now I mean needless to say if a
man ever openly confess that he enjoyed
making women
uncomfortable he would be fired from
whatever job he has probably like sent
to jail he certainly wouldn't be hired
to make the next Star Wars film nor
should he Because by the way um enjoying
making people uncomfortable is that's
not a that's not a normal thing for a
human being that's not that's not
healthy you should not enjoy now there
are times when it's necessary to cause
discomfort in other
people but you you should not enjoy
other people's
discomfort
okay that makes you that's the
definition of being like a
sadist that's the definition of
sadistic now all that to say it's like
no one is we're not
uncomfortable okay nothing that you can
say is making when you talk about the
patriarchy and men here it it's we're
not oh man this is uncomfortable this is
really I I feel like she's we're not
uncomfortable um we're
bored so that's the effect that you have
on on men is you you can make us
bored and like
irritated and we find you tedious and
dull and we don't want to be around you
but it's not a discomfort is not really
the word I would
use whatever word you use though this is
the kind of contempt that Disney has for
its audience that that even after a year
of failure brought on by politicized and
unoriginal films
they are now gearing up to make what is
sure to be their most politicized and
also most unoriginal film to
date it's become kind of a war of
attrition with the audience and they
assume that you'll eventually come back
and you'll start giving them your money
again especially if it's Star Wars
because it's Star Wars and you'll just
sort of dutifully show Even if you know
the movie is gonna suck you'll show up
anyway and give me your money cuz it's
Star Wars and this is what I
do that's what they're
assuming but now you need to prove them
wrong and make this the year that Disney
is once and for all finally canceled if
You' like to see what else I have to say
you can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed